use Twitter strategically if you just go
on and post a whole bunch of promotional
ads or aren't really paying attention to
people are saying about you you're not
going to get any value out of Twitter
might as well just leave it if you're
going to spend your time on something
you want to make sure you're getting
incredible value out of it otherwise
dumping a move on to something that
you're good at I recently came off of
Carnival Cruise and before I left I
tweeted them to say hey carnival I'm
coming on board here's the ship looking
forward to a great vacation you know
they responded with nothing at the very
least if you have a Twitter account you
want to respond to the people who are
talking to you at the very least what
got me interested in Twitter at first I
five this is stupid people talking about
their cats what date for lunch what
movie they're watching I don't care like
I got business to do but I went to
Twitter i did a search for my company
name my website and found out that
people were talking about me and I
wasn't a part of the conversation you
want to hang out where your customers
are so that's the that's the first thing
before you dump any promotional material
it on Twitter just listen and recognize
the people who are talking about you you
may have a really small business and
that's fine and you may not have a huge
amount of chatter but just by having a
Twitter account listed on your website
some people will seek you out and ask
you questions or talk to you mention you
somehow through Twitter so you need to
monitor the account at the very least
monitor your account the very least a
carnival should have done was right back
to me to say have a great trip the very
least that's what that's what I was
actually expecting I'm not expecting
great service I'm used to mediocre
service now from from the cruise line
industry but at the very least I was
expecting some kind of response to get
nothing is ridiculous what I would have
done
is not just thank the person if I was
running that Carnival Cruise Line
Twitter account I would find a way to go
above and beyond to recognize Twitter
person if you found my account you'd see
I've got hundreds of thousands of
followers very active and I would give
that person some kind of free bonus give
them a free internet package give them a
free dinner upgrade give them a free
tour these things cost nothing they
cause nothing for the cruise ship and
instead of me coming on slamming
carnival and saying how crappy there are
on their Twitter account I become insane
here's a company that gets it here's the
company who knows what they're doing and
would have cost them nothing they just
have the wrong strategy and the wrong
implementation and I know it's hard you
know it's hard you have a million things
to do why should you worry about Twitter
as well that's not like you have extra
two hours every day to sit there and be
on Twitter I get that and Carnival has a
team of people who manage their social
media they have 90 something thousand
followers listen I have twice as many
followers as carnival and I respond to
everybody who writes to me and I do it
personally it's not somebody on my team
writing for me it's me you write to me
on Twitter you get me responding to you
because I think it's important to
interact with the people who are talking
to me and talking about my business so
if I can do it the whole team of
Carnival can do it and you can do it if
you're a small company Yuri not have a
lot of chatter going on hey that's okay
i'm not saying build up a huge twitter
strategy it could work but at the very
least listen to what's going on and
recognize the champions who are talking
about your business because they're
going to keep doing it over and over and
over again so here are some quick steps
for you number one if you're not on
Twitter get on Twitter because people
are searching for you if they see your
website they'll often look for a Twitter
account now as a way to connect or as a
way to tell other people about you
so very least just set up the Twitter
account and you'll have it saved you
know nobody else can take your name
anymore don't start writing crap okay
everything you do should be great should
have meaning and purpose so don't just
start pumping out deals hoping that
you're going to get results it's not
going to happen step number two is just
listen see what people are saying about
you see if people are writing to you and
just thank them just listen if that's
all you do that's okay to start you've
opened up a new channel for people to
talk to you that's what you want the
next step if you're willing to do this
is start sharing some thought leadership
start talking about the things you
believe in start talking about the
things are having an impact on your
business so talking about the customers
that are using your your product or
service provide a value just like
anything else in business provide value
don't slam offers and crap down people's
throats they will not subscribe to your
channel you want people to listen give
them something to listen to what do you
know from your expertise your you should
be an expert in what you do what can you
share a limited number of characters
that will impact people's lives that'll
make their day better you should be an
expert and you need to share your
knowledge with people that's the next
step on Twitter and it doesn't have to
be crazy you don't have to post ten
times a day start with once a week and
build up from there but at the very
least carnival you guys got it wrong
thank the people recognize the people
who are talking about you it takes two
seconds and it's expected these days
it's like not answering the phone if I
can do it I spend my personal time on
top of running my business and running
my investments I have almost 200,000
followers you can do it on your account
and it's totally worth the effort to do
it believe if you guys like this video
please give it a thumbs up
lo it always thinks you want to do more
and I want to hear you have to think
please leave a comment below if you have
a question about your Twitter strategy
let me know and I'll answer it for you
if you want to share what you're doing
that's working let me know to a love
scene those come in I really do love
seeing the comments they make my morning
every day I'm eating my lentils and i
watch the comments come in and I respond
to you guys so you make me want to keep
doing these videos so thank you and I'll
see you soon